[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous les chérissait à
logbaba on est on dirait qu'il est 17h40
alpes où il est c'est la buzine comme
c'était logique ne fait pas de mal
on a tous déjà posé pour faire la
meilleure photo possible sur son compte
un star c'est vrai que quand on fait la
photo sur le compte un tas est mine de
rien on peut prendre leurs affaires la
cantine sans déconner ça veut dire qu'on
fait tout et et le plaisir on verrait
remarqué sur vous on fait tous la même
tout et on est quand même et tu mets le
téléphone un peu au come as tu connais
ou par m bah oui est-ce que vous aurez
le poêlon pour l'instant je ne sais pas
si vous voyez chez le vide et le pot de
gel aujourd'hui je retrouve plus on a
besoin de leur de leu leu disciplinaire
vous connaissez vous également donc la
voilà donc là pour l'instant je suis en
réflexion capillaire je ne vous le cache
pas géraldine ya jpp c'est une des
personnalités qui se fait le plus
remarquer par ses positions alors
préservé par tf1 pour faire attention à
sa santé
ça fait près de deux mois maintenant que
nous le voyons dans le jt de 13h faire
une pastille enfin du journal de jacques
loiseau et c'est devenu un vrai rendez
vous ça marche très fort mais depuis
lundi les téléspectateurs ont pu
remarquer que jean pierre pernaut était
absent du jt alors très vite les
internautes
tout le monde doit e c'est parce qu'il a
fait des coups de fouet
il a été censuré
jean pierre pernaut masse faire virer
mouais
jean pierre pernaut rend l'argent ouais
jean pierre pernaut a critiqué la maison
mère de tf1 broussy que ouais bon voilà
tout ça donc c'est parti aucun cas ouais
tu es les filtres maintenant avant il y
avait avec eux le café qui est avec
tulle trou sans fil du temps il ya les
meufs et les mecs ya les neuf et les
mecs avec jupe aux antilles se dire
qu'il ya un mec tu peux le voir sur un
stade c'est un beau gosse de ouf
tu le vois en vrai frère mais il est bi
classe mais deux coups le même et il ya
ce qu'ils aient filtré
ça veut dire que sans le laisser comme
d'où ça vient elle arrive elle arrive
parce qu'il vous que vous sachiez que
c'est clos quand elle arrive voilà elle
est dégueulasse elle est noire une fois
qu'elle est filtré elle est claire comme
de l'eau de roche
voilà la balle les mecs c'est pareil tu
vois un mec sur un statut très frais lui
attend sans déconner et là tu le vois
arriver mon frère en vérité tu croyais
qu'il avait les pectoraux en fait ces
dessins te dire que tu croyais qu'il
avait une coupe de films défaut grec
c'est vrai je te jure que c'est vrai tu
croyais qu'il avait une coupe de fou en
fait tu vois qu'il a hyper u ouest
pierre de weck
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
r ouais pour toi jean pierre pernaut il
est plein ouais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette société
pourrie rendez-le frêche
wen c'est toujours les mêmes ouais
acheta qu'est ce que ça veut dire
débilité ouais j'suis comme un fou en ce
moment dans les émissions de télé on a
tous l'impression d'être victoria
silvstedt on a tous l'impression de
faire une pub pour château d'ax parce
qu'on est tous sur son canapé
on peut les prendre et on peut dire que
c'est un truc de ouf on voit l'intérieur
en tout cas on avait l'intérieur de chez
tout le monde à chaque fois que je
croise aussi des policiers des trucs
comme ça c'est vrai que yves ils
viennent me voir et ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir je voulais vous
ragonnet 7 d'arca parce que ça m'étonne
pas c'est qu'il vous dit ça ils viennent
me voir et me voir comme si j'étais l'un
vis de l'intérieur il sait que par les
jambes je me dis que c'est ma sais pas
je crois ce quelqu'un c'est à monsieur
là deux minutes au pouvoir bon alors
vous avez un parce que bon la sueur là
on est on est on est douze là dans le
commissariat
on aimerait passer à 8 donc nous on
aimerait bien voir comment on pouvait
faire je fais mais les gars moi je veux
bien faire ce que tout ce que vous
voulez mais là je n'ai aucun pouvoir je
préfère vous que je le donne à qui vont
en découdre
ouais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
gouvernement de gauche ou verts
demandent aux droits de gouvernement du
milieu c'est la dernière et je voulais
vous dire merci de votre fidélité
je vous jure que c'est vrai hier vous
étiez encore 700 milles à nous regarder
c'est incroyable c'était une formule où
on s'est dit on avait l'impression
d'être j'étais chez vous voilà on avait
l'impression de vivre voilà en somme
dead de vivre les mêmes choses et c'est
vrai que c'était une expérience qui
restera pour moi un excellent souvenir
enfin de vous avoir accompagné c'est
vrai que tout ça ça restera un mauvais
souvenir pour nous toute cette histoire
de kobe 19
[Musique]